the views and opinions expressed on this
program are those of the guests
appearing on the program and do not
necessarily reflect the views and
opinions of 8 news now or next our media
group
tonight on politics now inflation crime
and education republican candidates for
governor lay out their plans plus
number one for ethnically diverse
senator jackie rosen gives us nevada's
pitch to become the first state to
nominate a president in the next step in
the process
and does working for the da's office and
being in the legislature violate
separation of powers you look at the big
decision in front of the state supreme
court
[Music]
from 8 news now
this is politics now
thank you for joining us here on
politics now i'm john langler the
republican race for governor is
tightening up as we close in on the june
primary this week nine candidates were
at a town hall forum joe mola was there
at a gubernatorial town hall tuesday
nine republicans answered the same
handful of questions first attorney joey
gilbert addressed the economy what do we
need to diversify in away from the
service industry sector away from mining
logistics manager tom heck wants to look
at taxes governors create an environment
where jobs can flourish
how is that done
by cutting taxes guy nora says he wants
to attract businesses
i'm coming in with my business
development people or i actually i close
the deal as the governor we need to show
them that it's important for them to
move here on crime sheriff joe lombardo
says he is paying attention to the
problems the national policies and the
state policies associated with crime the
attitude towards crime the softening of
sentences the softening of actual
criminals rights versus victims rights
on education former senator dean heller
says the district needs to be fixed is
it this school district's too large this
school district needs to be broken down
you take a complex problem and you make
it much less of a problem on the topic
of homelessness dr fred simon says from
the homeless veterans to mental health
it is a complex issue bipolar and
schizophrenic patients need proper
medication we need the legal
people in our state to recognize you
cannot
stabilize a patient in 48 to 72 hours
real estate investor barack zilberberg
wants a wellness community elon musk
which has 15 000
cubicles i'm gonna subdivide parcels so
we drop those cubicles in for fifteen
thousand and have a wellness community
eddie hamilton says we need more land
for affordable housing so we need
affordable housing to get that we gotta
have a lot of public land on water
concerns north las vegas mayor john lee
says the water nevada gets but doesn't
use needs to be saved instead of that
water going down we need to make sure
the reservoirs up at the top start
filling up their reservoirs again joe
mohler live local now
now after the forum former president
donald trump endorsed clark county
sheriff joe lombardo in the governor's
race the former president said quote joe
will fiercely protect our under siege
second amendment opposed sanctuary
cities support our law enforcement he
says lombardo according to former
president trump is the leader nevada
needs
current governor steve sisilak's
campaign responded with this quote it's
clear joe lombardo's campaign is hitting
the panic button after getting attacks
from all sides on the airwaves called
out for hiding ripped for having it both
ways on immigration
lombardo is also out with the first ad
paid for by his campaign a pac
supporting him has been running those
ads you've already seen on television
politicians they hide behind commercials
and social media trying to act tough a
bunch of keyboard cowboys they talk
tough about him the ad focuses on
violent crime and deportations
meanwhile democrats are preparing for
nevada to become the first state in the
2024 presidential nominating process the
person pitching nevada's case is senator
jackie rosen she spoke with eight news
now i-team reporter david charns
number one we're ethnically diverse we
look like the rest of the nation
we have a large hispanic community large
african-american community fastest one
of the fastest growing aapi communities
in the country we are union strong
we have
good voter access in our state two media
markets makes it easier and i would say
most importantly we are a battleground
state and so the path to the presidency
runs right through nevada so any
potential candidate should be listening
to what nevadans have to say what's
important to us we're going to reflect
what's up the rest of the nation
thinks and i think that's one of the
biggest reasons some of the biggest
reasons nevada should be first in the
nation
is your goal to have nevada be
first on its own day like we've seen in
iowa or new hampshire or are you cool
with
nevada south carolina iowa new hampshire
being their own
sort of first day altogether where do
you stand on that
well i'm going to leave that up to the
dnc to decide you know we submit a
letter of intent hoping to be first in
the nation we're going to argue our case
but of course it's ultimately up to them
but i do think that it is really
important that the first in the nation
or whatever the dnc decides it should
look like the rest of america tell me
about some of the work that goes into
this um
there was an article a couple weeks ago
that mentioned you working long hours in
the capitol working on some paperwork to
sort of get this done
um
what goes into your work
to try to do this on behalf of
democrats in nevada we'll be submitting
the letter of intent then the dnc will
schedule a time for advocates in the
state to come
argue our case and then the rules and
bylaws committee for the dnc will make
whatever decision they feel is right for
the entire nation do you think that the
previous
primaries and i'm not saying pick a
specific presidential year but do you
think that previous years could have
been different say nevada was first
because
we are diverse and maybe a different
candidate would have come out of nevada
than let's say
a first place candidate in iowa or new
hampshire
well it's hard to go back i'm going to
leave that to the historians to analyze
what might have happened if nevada was
first you know we've been first in the
west for the last a few cycles i think
four cycles it is and so i think that
we've shown
that we can
deliver that we know how to uh
bring candidates in to run those
grassroots efforts be sure that all of
nevadans are listening to the different
candidates and of course now that it's a
primary uh they'll be able to vote just
like they do in a regular election why
is senator rosen uh the the the
spearhead of this
i've had the time to do it i'm not on
the ballot this time so i've had a
little bit of time that i can devote to
this but let me tell you it is a unified
effort it is a team effort the governor
uh senator cortez masto our other
federal uh elected we're all talking
together of course with some so many
advocates up and down the state it's
been a unified team effort i've just
been able to be a little bit more
involved
because i'm not on the ballot this cycle
of course senator rosen's colleague
senator catherine cortez masto is up for
re-election one of her opponents senate
republican candidate adam laxalt
campaigned this week with his old navy
roommate florida governor ron desantis
wednesday's rise up rally had a crowd of
more than a thousand people over at
stoney's rock and country the pair
attacked woke culture and the radical
left they say they cited the collapse of
cnn plus that streaming service and they
also referenced tesla ceo elon musk
buying twitter both of those as proof
republicans they say are on the march
vice president kamala harris tested
positive for covet 19 this week she is
asymptomatic her office says the white
house says she hasn't had any contact
with president joe biden since april
18th vice president harris is currently
working from home
last weekend saw another murder at the
apex apartments it's the fourth one at
that property in the last year the
unlicensed apartment complex is near
twain and cambridge and the eight news
now i-team has been investigating it
since august and we've now learned
owners of the property benefited from
coronavirus relief money the i-team's
vanessa murphy tracked down the numbers
and the county commissioner who
represents the area
the apex apartments here are crime
ridden police are constantly here there
are deplorable conditions the county is
trying to take action in the meantime
the i-team has learned the owners have
been collecting public tax dollars so
where's our money go
they don't fix anything they don't help
us clark county spent more than 326
thousand dollars in the past year to
help tenants here pay back rent
according to a clark county spokesman
that's while conditions at the
unlicensed property have drastically
deteriorated california-based company
pro residential bought the place in
january of last year the county is now
suing the owners alleging they conspired
to illegally provide unsafe housing in
multiple states to collect coronavirus
relief money and schemed with criminal
enterprises for example allowing drug
dealers to advertise on signs in fact
this landlord will get county money to
support this is pretty crazy
commissioner tick sagerbloom who
represents this neighborhood says he was
here two weeks ago asking the owner to
make repairs and to hire security then
on sunday someone opened fire in the
courtyard they promised to have security
how could that happen if you have two
security officers here full time county
records reveal sunday marks the fourth
homicide in about a year here along with
nearly 700 calls for service a stabbing
19 shootings a swat search for a drug
house and 50 burglaries or robberies the
county alleges property managers aren't
willing to walk the halls here because
they know it's unsafe officers were on
standby during our visit with the
commissioner squatters are also an issue
here we saw one woman leave what was a
boarded-up unit they think about the
neighbors around i mean they're having
to live with this environment there's a
lot of kids that live here there's an
elementary school just down the road
commissioner sagerbloom says the county
is trying to avoid shutting the place
down but may have to and county reps
would help residents find a new home he
also says he wants to create a law
making the landlord's actions a criminal
felony they should be going to jail the
i-team's requests for an interview with
the owners have been ignored vanessa
murphy live local now
in a statement clark county said while
withholding chap funds from certain
landlords may have helped with other
concerns it would have also resulted in
evictions and homelessness for some
tenants which they added was their
primary concern
next on politics now separation of
powers the case which could force some
members of the legislature to find
another day job
plus a dramatic prisoner swap with
russia the people who still need to be
rescued
about ibrance
welcome back to politics now
clark county school district leaders are
hoping to take a step forward in
addressing concerns from the community
safety concerns the district hosted a
conversation on school safety during a
facebook live event this week comes
after several violent incidents across
the district at several different
campuses one issue ccsd is working to
fix the lack of counselors and social
workers
we're not where we want to be
as far as a comparison perspective with
other districts across the country but
we have partnered with outside
vendors to
you know help us attract and retain
social workers
school leaders say they have already
made improvements at el dorado high
school you'll remember that's where a
teacher was attacked a few weeks ago the
district is also looking to local police
to help with enforcement across the
district
a big setback for two republican
initiative petitions that are now in
court they could keep them from getting
on the ballot one is on voter id the
other rolls back the automatic mail-in
ballots judges in carson city ruled
language on the initiative was
misleading that means supporters have to
start over on getting 145 000 signatures
to get them on the ballot they have
seven weeks to collect those signatures
a lawyer for those initiatives is
republican attorney general candidate
seagal chatta
nevada's constitution has a separation
of powers clause that means people can't
work for two branches of government at
the same time so what counts as working
for the governor's office for some
people in the legislature the nevada
supreme court says it finally needs to
be ruled on by a court we spoke with an
attorney on the case colleen mccarty
what would the supreme court the state
supreme court be deciding
so there's really two issues
um the overarching issue
is whether or not it's a violation of
the nevada constitution under the
separation of powers clause for elected
legislators to also serve as government
employees that's the big question
what the supreme court decided
most recently
is whether or not
npri the nevada policy research
institute has what's known as standing
to bring the case
standing as a procedural mechanism or in
order for anybody to bring a lawsuit you
have to be able to allege unless there
are some exceptions that you have
personal harm and with respect to npri
what are some of the red flags that
stick out to you
about
uh
positions not necessarily not
necessarily people but positions
that might come up where someone is say
you know
working
for a judge but then is also making law
like what are some examples
so one of the defendants in our case
nicole cannizzaro
until recently was a prosecutor in the
clark county district attorney's office
and also a state lawmaker and so in that
position essentially she has the ability
to not only make the laws
but then turn around and enforce the
laws
and certainly we argued uh in our brief
that uh during the last legislative
session there were a number of items on
the agenda related to uh criminal
justice reform including the death
penalty so the question then becomes if
i'm working as a government employee
whether i'm a prosecutor whether i'm a
teacher whether i'm
any sort of government employee does
that impact how i behave how i vote what
issues are important to me in the
legislature so this issue has been
percolating for decades
there are a number of attorney general's
opinions about it there are a number of
legislative council bureau opinions on
it npri has brought suit twice and uh
not made it up to the nevada supreme
court for procedural issues
again uh this third time around in the
lower court npri was denied based on a
procedural issue that standing issue we
talked about but the nevada supreme
court said no
this time we are going to allow this
case to proceed because we think it's a
matter of public importance
there's a lot of
crossover with people who are
in one
branch and in another branch
so if this were to
if you were to succeed
and
whoever makes their final ruling says
yeah you can't do both
do you think that would really upend
a lot of people in the legislature
so there are a number of people who are
no longer in the case because of
resignations or they decided not to run
again i know we have another one that we
didn't include initially who now fits
into the category
so we've got about
nine or ten
uh defendants at this point i think
and they are both democrats and
republicans
but i think the bigger question really
is
do we want to continue this practice as
a state of allowing people who serve as
lawmakers to also essentially work in
positions where they're
enforcing those laws furthering those
laws
and do we want to continue to have a
legislature that may be conflicted
because their
employers come to the legislature asking
for things
mccarty is a former eight news now
i-team reporter now the case is going to
head back to the lower court and will
decide the bigger question no matter
what happens though it is likely we'll
get appealed to the state supreme court
a federal judge says he will decide in
the next few weeks if the execution of
zane floyd is going forward floyd was
convicted of killing three people and
sentenced to death in 2004 the judge in
the case says key questions about the
execution method are still unanswered a
supply of sedatives expired at the end
of february and state detention
officials
they say they cannot get more there's
also no active death warrant on the case
right now the judge says he'll make a
decision by may 16th
dealing with the border next on politics
now the role a public health emergency
is playing in our current policy there
and the debate over whether it should
stay or go
now
you're watching politics now
relations between the u.s and russia are
at their lowest point in years and at
the heart as you can imagine is the war
in ukraine still a dramatic prisoner
swap between both the u.s and russia was
pulled off this week the u.s was given
back marine veteran trevor reed he spent
nearly a thousand days in russian
custody after being convicted for
assaulting someone while drunk an
allegation he denies in exchange the u.s
released a russian who had served 20
years for drug smuggling reid's family
says the exchange was worth it
president biden saved our sons alive
today a perfect mother's day almost as
good as the day he was born
the u.s is still working to free other
americans in custody in russia including
women's basketball player brittany
griner
the debate over immigration policy
heating up in washington d.c a federal
judge recently blocked the bite
administration from ending a president
trump era policy called title 42 rashad
hudson has that story
late monday a federal judge threw a
wrench in the government's plan to lift
title 42 through a temporary restraining
order missouri attorney general eric
smith says it was the right decision
it's a big win i think for border
security and the rule of law the trump
air policy allows migrants seeking
asylum to be expelled through a pandemic
health policy louisiana senator john
kennedy and senate republican leader
mitch mcconnell say there's no reason to
make a change one of the most foolish
ideas coming from an administration that
has become famous for foolish ideas
pulling back the title 42 authorities
will only make it
dramatically worse
it's not just republicans who are
raising concerns about changes to the
policy democrats are also warning the
administration about rolling it back
west virginia senator joe manchin also
wants it to remain in place and
basically protect our people and
citizens united states and making sure
the people coming are coming for the
right reason but ohio senator sherrod
brown says title 42 is no longer needed
because the country is at a different
place
in the pandemic we have had
pretty incredible success in fighting
this pandemic
and getting shots in people's arms the
future of the policy will likely be a
major topic when homeland security
secretary alejandro mayorkas testifies
to the house judiciary committee later
this week reporting in washington rashad
hudson
all democrats in nevada's delegation are
against lifting title 42 until more
permanent plans in place they are in
favor though of getting rid of it
eventually politics now is back after
this
[Music]
three three three three
[Music]
this week in what to watch potentially
raising fees on businesses the southern
about southern nevada health district is
considering raising an environmental
health fee paid by most small businesses
the department says it needs to make up
budget losses from inflation the special
meeting to discuss this will be held on
thursday we will have coverage of that
and more political news coming up this
week here on eight news now
thank you for watching politics now we
do appreciate it of course for all the
latest political news just head to
8newsnow.com you'll be all caught up
we're back with you next saturday we
thank you so much for joining us take
care